a Bill O'Reilly failed Fox News host
Bill O'Reilly has come out of the
woodwork with advice for Herschel Walker
and I promise this is it for Herschel
Walker's stuff for the week unless
something insane happens it's this is
really it for Herschel Walker stuff this
is more about Bill O'Reilly Bill
O'Reilly put together some advice for
Herschel Walker that I have to tell you
in some way makes sense which is a weird
thing to say about anything Bill
O'Reilly had to say take a look he's
been on this program I know him a little
bit
but every two weeks there's another
Scandal about Herschel Walker and the
latest one is that
um
he had a girlfriend and he paid for an
abortion
for the girlfriend
now
the news agency to put that out is a far
left
revolting news agency jelly Beast
The Daily Beast actually does some
pretty good reporting but okay yeah it's
like okay
and Walker went on Hannity last night
and said this go I never asked anyone to
get an abortion I never paid for an
abortion and it's a lie and I'm going to
continue to fight you know I'll tell you
that's what they want they want this
seat
okay
here's what you got to do Herschel and
and I'm just talking to you like a human
being here please this is a serious
accusation
if you did it
you got to say it did it I don't know
how you do that but
you can't lie about it especially at
this point how do you do it if you did
not do it
then you got to go after The Daily Beast
you got to have your attorneys sue them
and if there is a person alleging that
she had an abortion you got to see that
person yeah now remember that Herschel
Walker three days ago said tomorrow
morning we're filing a defamation suit
as of this moment no such suit has been
filed and that's a really common thing
that happens in the sort of celebrity
and politics space which is you say
you're going to file a defamation suit
but of course if it's true it's not
defamation and as Michael Cohen
mentioned when I appeared on his program
we recorded an episode
if filing that lawsuit opens up
Discovery and you might end up getting
deposed and so you really don't do it
unless it's actually defamation
if you did not do it and you have to do
that now
so that the people in Georgia who are
going what the deuce is this right every
two weeks we got another child fathered
by Mr Walker or this or whatever but if
this is not true
then your lawyers have to mobilize now
yeah and why aren't they and you have to
hold a press conference with your
lawyers and you have to say this is
false imagine Herschel Walker trying to
read a statement at a press conference
and going completely off the rails never
happened and we're going to file this
Against The Daily Beast now if you do
that and indeed if you did not pay for
an abortion then that will turn that
race around hmm you'll win your seat
maybe because Georgians will see you
rightly as a victim of this smear
but if you did it
you're gonna lose right even if you
admit you did yeah so I mean Bill
O'Reilly's kind of right here only
insofar as Walker doesn't actually have
to admit that it's true
but if he doesn't and he keeps denying
it in increasingly less credible ways
and we learn more and more about the
alleged truth and that includes that not
only is this woman someone who had an
abortion after being impregnated by
Walker but is also the mother of one of
his kids it's going to become a very
difficult story to credibly deny so I
have to say to some degree
Bill O'Reilly giving some sensible
advice
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of Chilly sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night